but I'm going to tell you guys you're in
college so most of you have probably
tried some sort of a drug I was never a
fan of drugs I tell you I was never a
fan of drugs that doesn't matter in
trying I just saw I'm not a fan of them
right I tried almost all of them but the
reason why I didn't like him is because
it's controlled it controlled me and I
couldn't think I like to be in control I
don't like when things are controlling
me and drug controls you I don't I don't
need an escape for me to go to lala land
I want to make my life and escape I'm
gonna make my life so cool that I am the
escape earth is the escape for me from
reality that most people live and I
realize guys out of all the drugs as the
most incredible sex most incredible
things you do there is nothing the most
incredible highs in life are all natural
highs I prefer natural highs that's what
I seek
i'ma encourage you to seek natural highs
all the other stuff is temporary how
long does sex last the best one then
you're tired and then it's like okay you
go to sleep how long does highs last
with sick with frickin pot an hour where
where does shrooms do take your whole
different place what does cocaine make
you feel like you can conquer the world
for thirty minutes what is exha tea to
ecstasy to get you a massage but a
special can all the other crap to waste
the time to waste the time when you're
winning
imagine being high for 50 years holy
good I'm freakin high non-stop now
that's a high right and I know it's you
guys are gonna probably leave a little
confused tonight you guessing he'll be
this guy and like to date man you said
everything you're not supposed the same
man but it's the truth and that's that's
my thoughts so going back to question on
scheduling its all day every day
non-stop and then once you make it then
who do you want to be because when you
start making monies when you really
learn a lot about yourself so what are
you guys going to do when you start
making a quota millionaire it's easy to
say I'm gonna go for a half you don't
know that do you know how many guys a
quarter million slowly you know what
quarter million is let me tell what a
quarter million is Quartermain is a
$7,000 mortgage payments putting
that's a million-dollar house okay
quarter million is a nice $2,000 car
payment it's an s550 that's an SL 63
that's a Porsche 911 everyone's checking
you out
quarter million got a nice Rolex watch
or brightening watch if you want it
quarter mil you don't go to Macy's you
don't even go to Nordstrom's you're
going straight to Neiman Marcus so I
didn't know how to slow down we don't
know that here's a reality demo
most of you guys look at me as an old
fart because I'm 38 right I talked to
one the catch is like you all yeah you
kind of seem like old to us you know
it's like you seem like old man to us
because you're twice our age great do
you know I'm counting on your inventions
like our generations counting on your
innovations like we are truly relying on
what you guys are going to be doing
because you 100 percent of world's
problems guys I'm at Harvard Business
School
there's a party everyone's got to go up
there pitch I'm one of the 16 people
that pitches in front of a couple
hundred people I believe 100% of all of
world's problems are going to be solved
by entrepreneurs 100% 100% of all of
world's palms are going to be solved by
entrepreneurs I 100 and believe that
100%
watch this I'm at Harbor business where
everybody's kitchen door opportunity one
guy gets up and pitches and he says
here's what we have invented we have
invented a technology that tells the
city the state the county to expect an
earthquake in three minutes we give a
three-minute warning we're like get out
of here let me show you the technology
we're literally similar like oh my gosh
how many people have been killed for
earthquakes to see out last year did you
see it only what happened hundreds and
hundreds some people died for me and
only earthquakes we don't worry about in
America because the buildings are built
solid but what about some places they
don't have the best things being built
another guy in a Lagos Africa people
don't have water we're okay with water
here but one the biggest world promised
today that everybody's fearing is what
water this company starts this machine
it's a hundred million dollar plan to
create it produces a million gallons of
water every day from air air this water
problem is done because of entrepreneurs
next guy comes up with cancer
I'm sitting and I'm saying man
entrepreneurs are going to rock the
world we have 7.2 billion people living
in the world today only 400 entrepreneur
coin a million entrepreneurs that's 5.7
percent not enough we need to take that
to 20 percent we take that to 20 percent
you know what can be figured out any
problem pick it I don't give a what
it is any problem is going to be solved
by entrepreneurs any problem will be
solved by entrepreneurs you know why
because if you don't figure down you're
going out of business you don't have to
figure out the solution at your job you
still have a job tomorrow
so we sit down like King what do you
think about this bro what are we going
to do give me a pen give me a paper what
if we did this you know what we gotta
call this guy we got to get ahold of
this guy call this how can we get home
and see if anybody's got any mutual
friend I got three mutual friends were
the guys Mary Jake the message of how do
they know Bobby I'll keep this school
nobody knows Bobby they went to school
to get a contract Mary hey kid Mary can
you give us Bobby's phone number Bobby
knows Jackie hey Bobby when can we get
together man we understand you did this
this this yeah okay Gregg here we go hey
Bobby this is what we got no what do you
think about this oh my gosh you guys got
to talk to Jack that's exactly what to
talk to we got to talk to Jack well what
am I going to get out we don't kill with
10% let's do do I want 20% wait let's do
this quick Jack Jack Neil Olsen oh my
gosh that's entrepreneurs you don't have
to do this as a job but you got to do
this as an entrepreneur 100% of world's
problems are going to be solved by
entrepreneurs we only have five point
seven percent of our population that's
entrepreneurs and we have some countries
that have the most ridiculous Minds ran
on a communistic system that doesn't
give birth to entrepreneurs that's the
problem because you know what a
communistic system does to entrepreneurs
you just goes wham shut up stop thinking
we don't care we tell you what to do we
have all the Proms know what I'm telling
you be quiet so we have an economical
system that's broken that doesn't work
because of a guy wrote a book called
Karl Marx called Communist Manifesto
that universities are fascinated by both
wise these are terrible people
Laura teri yaad oh my gosh was nice
noble people
really really
when we're young we want to save every
prom in the world and we want to do
world peace and we want to make sure
taxes go up to 60 70 percent you know
why cuz you're not paying taxes you
don't care if taxes go to 90 percent no
it's not fair these rich people are so
greedy really I haven't met many rich
greedy people rich people are so greedy
they're so greedy Wow what makes them
greedy tell me what makes them greedy
too greedy people rich people agree two
people I grew up on a family my mother
was 100% communist my father is a
hundred percent imperialist you know
it's imperialism it's crazy stuff okay
you know it's communism it's crazy stuff
so I grew up a confuses omim you know
whatever you want to call it what the
heck is going on your man one side
saying which people are terrible people
the other side saying poor people are
lazy I'm like oh my gosh maybe they're
both maybe there's a little bit of both
going on so on one end people ask why
are you doing value taming I got a book
that I wrote it's a fiction book that
none of my family members wants to
publish because if I publish it it's a
very controversial book but the purpose
of value tainment
I'm not making money off value taming
why do you keep making these videos man
we need the world to buy into
entrepreneurship we need these dumb
economical systems to be converted to
capitalism because it works do you
realize how much good you're going to do
when you make money if you got a good
heart what the hell you think you're
going to do when you have when you have
a good heart when you make money listen
this is how money works if you're a jerk
and you're broke you know what happens
when you're a billionaire
you're a jerk billionaire but if you're
giving when you're broke guess what
happens when you're billionaire you're
giving and we got to get these giving
people who are poor to become rich the
hard-working people
not the ones that say I don't think it's
fair no one cares if it's not fair no
one I'm telling you right now no one
cares that this cat was born in a family
that mom and dad got a divorce and I had
a 1.8 GPA my dad's working at a 99-cent
store in Inglewood and I'm living in
Granada Hills my mother goes back
Ron and I go every time I go to school
my counselors look at me like this son
it's okay
not everyone's supposed to go and do big
things I think military is a great fit
for you sweetheart you don't know how to
read very well because business is tough
and school is tough to school to the
military and I'm like okay you're right
I'm not supposed to do anything you're
right I mean my dad was a 99 cents or
maybe you're right maybe you're right
man I almost bought into that I almost
bought into that somebody closed me on
that deal hell no we're not being sold
on that deal and I finally questioned it
no you're not selling me on this deal
not doing it stop it
I'm not buying it that's your sale
you're not going to sell me here that's
a sale over it I'm not buying I'm all
pay full price
what's full price I'll bust my ass to
get the full price because I won't
control you are not going to dictate
what this guy's going to do with his
life neither are you going to do my kids
not going to happen period tell my kids
you know I got three kids the oldest one
four-year-old he's got a three-year-old
brother and a three or brother it's like
you feel as calves
I just guys got calves like seriously
guys thick the walks are like this right
like this but it's older brother keeps
polina and a younger one is like six
months old she has no clue what's going
on she just beautiful right so I said my
older brother older son down I said
listen son in this family there's four
things you gotta before you do these
four things you're never gonna have
problems with your daddy
what is the four things daddy you got a
lead in any situation you're in you got
to respect people you got to improve and
you better love people because
everyone's dealing with some kind of
okay you got a buddy yes tell me
the four daddy and you tell us Manson
here's another thing let me take the
other thing is do you know what a bully
is no I'm going to show you what a bully
is okay he's thinking it's a fun game
this is not a fun game I so ready here's
what a bully is give me your shirt and
I'll go take it off I think that's my
favorite shirt you just bought it from
these doughnuts give me your give me
your pen give me my shoes no give it to
me and you run I push him in the back
because that's what he does to his
brother I pushed you like that no that's
what you
you like that no it's a come here let's
go it's a pop there's two things in our
family one we don't bully anybody you
bully anybody I guarantee you no one's
gonna bully you're more than I'm gonna
bully you and ain't no bully gonna be
bigger than me
is that clear yes and number two no one
believes us let me say it against you no
one bullies us no one does no one
bullies this family do you understand
that yes so now both of them are saying
daddy David family we don't bully people
and daddy no one bullies us and then I
asked them look what happens here so
daddy who loves you pop he says daddy
you love me pop I said daddy who
believes that your daddy he says me
meaning himself like all Manas powerful
because as I believe in me like you're
right pop you believe in you and half
this game is a mental battle I didn't
believe in myself
simple as that someone convinced me I'm
just supposed to be a regular cat goes
to the military I give 20 years I come
out and I work at a place as a civil
engineer somewhere you know whatever I'm
gonna make 72 grandeur and I got my
twenty two hundred dollar pension from
the army man you did good bro you did
good there's a place for that I respect
anybody that does serve the military
there's a place we're doing that but if
you have more upside my goal is to
maximize your upside that's purely it
the rest it is what it is okay so it was
a long winded that's why it wasn't two
minutes with Pat it was like seven
minutes with Pat okay all right next
question there was a lot of answers in
down one yes
uh so have you ever ran a business or
not yet but you sold something okay and
how long you did door-to-door which we
have something to write on it'd be so
much easier if we had something can I
write on that but that's got to come up
and got to turn that off like and can
you do that probably can you hand the
letter now now can you do that or knows
that a way we can increase this because
I can write a lot more visually so Paul
do you have the GoPro on where's the
GoPro land okay okay got it
if we can increase that move that up I
can explain it to you so let's stay
while he's doing that lets you and I
talk guys let's try to not get
distracted just stay with me stay here
they'll try to figure it out stay with
me they'll figure it out stay here stay
here it's okay
they'll come back stay here it's okay
believe me if you can't stay focused as
an entrepreneur you're screwed stay
focused okay all right okay so what do i
do do I go get a job or do I go and
start the business now if I the startup
idea in Hollywood have you guys noticed
in Hollywood that the same five actors
or three actors play the same types of
movies every year and they come up with
a movie like Adam Sandler has the same
what squad a Vince Vaughn Favreau and
these guys have the what same squad like
Jennifer Lawrence did what movie with
Bradley Cooper crazy movie silver
lawmakers have seen the Silver Line was
unbelievable movie and then they did
another one again that came after that
because they connect so they keep going
again again again again okay just like
in Hollywood you're doing that and the
actors find a team imagine if you and I
like think about if you saw one day I'm
playing poker
12 years ago I'm playing poker at some
Hollywood Park and it's late eleven
twelve o'clock at night main head table
as Jon Favreau Vince Vaughn and another
guy that's their friends who did the
Christmas story back in the days you
guys probably haven't seen Christmas
Story okay
and I'm sitting there playing poker with
these guys I have no clue what they're
doing so it's easy five grand you made
in and I cuz they're cool they don't get
to them like at that time five grand
nothing all in all and all and they got
two tens so
but I stayed six hours with them we
became buddies conversation was
phenomenal if you get into that circle
you're automatically an actor right
automatic guilty by association so the
one thing if you are going to become an
entrepreneur and see if you got a good
team like if you guys are here in school
find out who's a sharpest cat here that
has opposing strengths to you not saying
opposing personality to you not saying
okay first build this if you can build
this honestly forget about the rest
because all I need is I need three minds
in a marker and a board that's all I
need so then what are you going to do
let's go through the formula what is it
people stand up on this or what's this
here okay all right stand up
so now here's the next thing you do very
simple you go through industries so
write down the industries
telecommunication okay media financial
okay right every one of these industries
that you have when you write these
industries identify the problems one two
three
identify the problems then see if
anybody is trying to solve those
problems then find out if that person
that's trying to solve these problems
how good are they doing are they myspace
are they friends there are they Facebook
big difference they're all doing the
same thing but Friendster had no clue
what they were doing and in myspace was
just about the money and Facebook the
guy's legit so are they friend stir are
they MySpace or their Facebook if
they're Friendster myspace hey maybe
there's an opportunity for Facebook okay
that's this part next have you guys all
read blue ocean strategy or no must must
must must so three million copies blue
ocean strategy is a concept you got to
read before you start your business
implosion strategy talks about how most
people are in a shark
infested ocean where all the sharks are
trying to do what eat each other and
eventually you don't have food who do
you start eating each other so the ocean
is red to doggy-dog type of an
environment they recommend to go into a
blue ocean a blue ocean has no sharks
you buy yourself make sense so how do
you create a blue ocean strategy formula
you got to create you got to eliminate
you got to increase you got to decrease
whatever somebody is doing this formula
taking and applied to let's just pick
snapchat okay
snapchat what can we eliminate with
snapchat for instance if you could
snapchat a delete eliminate anything
with snapchat what would you do what do
you not like about snapchat app it's a
tough search so what are you going to do
so that's more on the create right so
let's just say we're going to go easier
to search is that fair that's just one
thing so we're going to increase search
let's talk about create you know what's
a terrible thing about creating on the
snapchat no one knows how many followers
anybody has so the spirit of competition
for people to go get more followers is
what not there so what if we create a
snapchat and we have followership I'm
just throwing it out we're not doing
this I'm just trying to show you how to
spawn a little would work okay what do
we minimize what do we make lower you
know what do we make less take a part of
snapchat and what can we decrease and
then take a part of snapchat and what
can we eliminate pick a part that you
want to eliminate then you are a blue
ocean you're not snapchat you're blue
ocean lift versus uber can you tip on
uber no lifts as you can that's the
point so you say every time you're done
with an uber so Lipsett Buber is for who
customers lips customers who drivers so
lift this focus on drivers ubers focused
on who customers lip is not going to be
as big as uber but it still became a few
billion dollars
because their focus was what let's make
sure the drivers are going to be able to
get what tip so everybody here who hates
the fact that they don't get what tips
is going to come to whoo this is a
formula so pick a team build your team
solid team go through the industries
identify the problems how would you
solve it was there already
take the blue ocean strategy formula and
then from there you know go attack now
have you ever worked under a killer is
your father successful entrepreneurs
they're an uncle and your family that's
very good at business I don't know okay
you're at Texas A&M - so Texas A&M is a
solid school and you guys are not here
by luck you're either from a very
successful family or you're sharp as
hell it's one of the - okay you didn't
get lucky to get here okay
there's somebody in your family very
successful who business or career so you
have you watch them grow their business
and do very good at it very good for
themselves yeah but she still kept some
over wealth for one business didn't work
is she losing everything or just this
business is being losing everything it's
okay it's going to happen if you want to
business you ain't even going to win
every single one of them you're going to
have some failures right so on that end
I don't know if you know work ethic yet
that's the scariest part about business
if you don't know how to work you got to
work under somebody's going to kick your
ass and toughen you up this business
world is a very very there's sharks in
this world man and they want to eat you
up
they want to make sure you don't make it
they want to kill you and business you
better believe that's exactly how it is
we're supposed to not ever have sex save
ourselves get married in our church and
then that's the best way to do because
that's what makes it work okay
take a hundred people and they do that
I'll say like wait a minute you guys
were married for 20 years and that they
feel like they miss a part of their
lives and one-sheets and they get a
divorce what he'll take it by the book
and there's another couple save
themselves they don't have sex they get
married in it forever together and
they're very happy every argument has an
argument that didn't work but you got to
pick one that works for who for you and
you just got to work with odds you
increase in decrease your odds when I
was getting married to my wife about a
book on a second date the book was
called 101 questions to ask before you
get engaged second date I said a week
from now when I get together with you if
you're open to this I'm going to go
through every question that's answered
I've already done this exercise with
three other girls I just want to kind of
want to see where you're at
cool I that's exactly what I did week
later six hours later I'm like yeah this
is it and a year and a half later after
the true because you know first six
months it's all acting oh babe I love
flowers
I just like to look at flowers and you
know where it takes me babe when I look
at flowers I get connected to God it's
like a spiritual connection like I feel
I'm I'm hanging out with Deepak Chopra
and it was like we're like Oprah's there
and we're just looking at it and we're
like I just we're somewhere else you
know what I'm saying baby hot babe I
totally feel it man you're so connected
with your emotions I am baby
six months later how do you feel about
flowers I'm so sensitive to allergy Bay
I can't stand flowers
wait a minute you just tell me I was
acting baby it was like trying to
impress you but you're not into deep
what are you gonna do leave go ahead you
know it's like one of those things so
for the first six months dating is a
bunch of BS but everyone's acting a fake
so don't believe anybody for the first
six months so you don't get married in
for six months hang tight about 12
months you're like oh you are a psycho
okay entertaining so yeah there's
no one formula okay and by the way don't
compare yourself to anybody you're
living your life you're building your
life I had a group of guys that came
together with me yesterday who they flew
in they run a very very successful debt
settlement company they can sell the
company today for 30 million
but they're upset because one of their
friends from high school is making more
money than them and they're doing solar
and I said who cares what that guy is
doing I didn't want to say but I knew it
because that's the competitors stop so
listen stop that's great you're
competitive you get out the spirit of
competition and in the world of business
if you don't you're going to get killed
but whose life are you building it
builds on your life go build your life
you're gonna be fine
okay next yes I run a financial firm yes
[Music]
so you're going to work under your
father so what do I suggest for you to
do to take the business globally I don't
know your business
okay got it
and how well are you doing there right
now what's the long-term goal would like
you when you and your father sit down
what is the company's long-term goal
I get it but what's your long-term
vision with that that's the mission
right so the mission is I make the
billion here's what I'm going to do to
give back but what is the vision of the
business how big do you want to build it
are you saying it right now because it's
the right thing to say do you really
believe that because you're stuttering
so is it fully clear is that is that 100
you're not bullshitting me like you're
really saying because that is that a
vision though okay all right
so what other markets are close to yours
that you can go into right now when you
can test okay so start with testing then
go fully big you know our company PHP
agency' we started off with California
everybody started saying hanging pad we
have to go into New York
we just got approved in New York four
months ago okay oh my gosh we got to go
into Boston Massachusetts we just gotta
prove us in three months ago
okay so initiative when you're building
a business you're going to think locally
and then you build globally right
sometimes you grow too fast globally you
lose uber went into China it didn't work
out they lost three and a half billion
okay so you got to know if it makes
sense what markets have a need for the
product you're marketing and it can you
test it start small and then grow big
small grow big but don't go into too
many markets too fast
why did Hitler not leave the entire
world do you know why who knows why you
want he spread himself too thin you
realize if he doesn't go to Russia and
doesn't lose the people in Siberia he is
one country over there and these people
are tired so you got to make sure you to
be remember the word entrepreneurs what
sales and what that's the strategy
Parkman you're going to get judged on
the strategies you create so I don't
have enough information to tell you
exactly what to do figure out what
market is comparable to yours and go
test that market yes
marriage apparently Burma for
entrepreneurs so what would you
recommend a way to develop one memory so
I did a video called how to retain
information on value tame and maybe
write it down and go watch it I go very
very detail into it it's like 30 minutes
look it's a game it's truly a game for
instance I'll give you an idea you know
what's hard a lot of people's memories
and especially a younger generation
here's what hurts the memory I grew up
in a time that I had to remember phone
numbers you don't have to remember phone
numbers so today you don't have to
answer anything everything is what
Google so you know how we go like this
watch this you're like almost the name
of that movie this is what we do today
Papa Papa don't do that try to find it
in your brain because you know it it's
in here play the game
what's your name and your brain goes
tick tick tick tick tick tick tick tick
tick tick Oh
gladiator that's what the brain does so
let it go don't just go straight to
Google and because Google's brain is
getting stronger now yours so play it
again
[Music]